[Applause]
from the earliest years of her reign
to the more recent this is the queen
we've become used to seeing active
available and in very good
health as recently as last year despite
the persistence of a pandemic she
maintained a packed schedule in the
space of just a few weeks in october she
opened parliaments in scotland and wales
planted trees in balmoral
and launched the commonwealth baton
relay in buckingham palace
but shortly after there were signs the
schedule was taking its toll she was
seen using a walking stick for the first
time at a major public event a royal
british legion service in westminster
abbey and after a night in hospital she
was advised to take it easy her family
stood in for her on remembrance day a
scheduled speech at cop26 delivered
remotely we are privileged to bring this
latest camera record of their royal
highnesses with their baby son prince
charles of edinburgh now eight months
old
but in her 95 years she has barely ever
been ill she battled measles when prince
charles was a baby meaning she couldn't
see him for a period but the first time
she was ever admitted to hospital wasn't
until the 80s a wisdom tooth extraction
the same year she met reagan
and other than surgery on her knees
she's hardly ever been back
her previous most recent stay in 2013 a
bout of gastroenteritis
the palace has been relatively
tight-lipped over the years about the
state of the queen's health but her work
rate and general reluctance to take time
away from her duties has in many ways
spoken for itself what we do know is
that she's remained remarkably active
well into her 90s being seen for example
during the pandemic riding her horses in
the grounds of windsor castle
her love of this sport and these animals
has no doubt helped keep her fit as well
as her team of world-class doctors but
this pandemic has targeted the elderly
even those triple jabbed people may well
feel worried but doctors say she'll be
well looked after
anyone who's a more serious risk
of the impact of curving 19
would be assessed by healthcare
professional
their blood oxygen levels would be
monitored
and if they were at risk
of more serious disease then they would
be eligible and would probably receive
treatment with the new antivirals or
potentially antibody treatment that's
now available these are very effective
treatments if given very early
throughout the pandemic she's stuck
tight to the rules most powerfully
poignantly at prince philip's funeral
any thought she'd slow down in the wake
of her loss clearly didn't come to pass
instead she's been led as always by duty
with a keen sense of humor in tow how's
that are you supposed to be looking at
as if you're enjoying it yes
she may feel at least this virus won't
stop her helen and smith sky news
windsor